democracy was achieved by such a long
arduous and heroic struggle that it can
feel embarrassing even shameful to be
pretty disappointed by it perhaps the
best guy to such feelings and to modern
democracy in general is a 19th century
french aristocrat alexis de tocqueville
photo Tocqueville democracy was a highly
exotic and new political option he'd
been born in 1805 when Napoleon was the
populist dictator of half of Europe but
he prescient Lee believed that democracy
was going to be the future all over the
world and so he wanted to know what
would that be like to find out he set
out to America with a grant from the
French government he arrived in New York
together with his friend who stabbed a
boomer in May of 1831 and then embarked
on a nine-month journey around the new
nation after his journey he compiled his
thoughts into one of the greatest works
of political philosophy democracy in
America published in 1835 in the book de
Tocqueville was particularly alive to
the problematic and darker sides of
democracy
five issues struck him in particular in
France the society that the Tocqueville
knew from childhood making money didn't
appear at the forefront of people's
minds the poor had almost no chance of
acquiring wealth and the tiny upper
stratum of landed aristocrats didn't
need to make any more money as a result
for very different reasons money was not
the way to judge a life however the
Americans that de Tocqueville met on his
journey believed constantly that through
hard work it was possible to make a
fortune and to do so was entirely
admirable and right money seem to be
quite simply the only achievement that
Americans respected for example the top
fill observed that in America people
believed that a book that did not sell
well just couldn't be any good because
the only test of goodness for any item
was how much money it happens to make
democracy and capitalism had thus
created seemingly equitable but also
very flat
an oppressive way for humans to judge
each other in a chapter of democracy in
America entitled why the Americans are
often so Restless in the midst of their
prosperity de Tocqueville sketched an
enduring analysis of the relationship
between high expectations and
dissatisfaction between political
equality and envy he wrote when all the
prerogatives of birth and fortune have
been abolished when every profession is
open to everyone an ambitious man may
think it is easy to launch himself on a
great career and feel that he has been
called to no common destiny but this is
a delusion which experience quickly
corrects when inequality is the general
rule in society the greatest
inequalities attract no attention but
when everything is more or less level
the slightest variation is noticed that
is the reason for the strange melancholy
often haunting inhabitants of
democracies in the midst of abundance
and of that disgust with life sometimes
gripping them even in calm and easy
circumstances the old rigid hierarchical
European system that had denied all hope
of social movement to the poor was
unjust in a thousand all too obvious
ways to Tocqueville recognized but it
had offered those on the lower rungs one
notable freedom the freedom not to have
to take the achievements of quite so
many people in society as reference
points and then find themselves severely
wanting in status and importance as a
result typically we think of democracy
as being the opposite of tyranny but de
Tocqueville noticed that democracy could
easily create its own specialized type
of tyranny that of the majority
Democratic culture he thought often ends
up demonizing any assertion of
difference an especially cultural
superiority even though such attitudes
might be connected with real merit in a
tyranny of the majority a society has an
aggressive leveling instinct it's
regarded as a civic virtue to take on
anyone who seems to be getting above
themselves
and to cut them viciously down to size
the tocqueville was disturbed by the way
in which in the united states people
have no distinction refused to think
that anyone could be better than them
just because they had say trained to be
a doctor for seven years or study the
law for two decades or written some very
good books a healthy and admirable
reluctance to defer to people too easily
encouraged an unhelpful refusal to
accept any kind of submission at all and
yet as the Tocqueville saw it it simply
must be the case that some people in
society are wiser more intelligent
kinder or more mature than others and
therefore should be listened to with
special attention democracy was the
Tocqueville thought fatally biased
towards mediocrity you suppose that
democracy would encourage citizens to
have an open mind
however de Tocqueville came to the
opposite conclusion that one could find
few places with less independence of
mind and true freedom of discussion than
in America trusting that their system
was fair and just Americans simply gave
up on critical thinking and put their
faith in newspapers and so called common
sense instead furthermore as this was a
commercial society Americans were very
conscious of not wanting to step too far
out of line with their neighbors who
might also be customers it was better to
trot out cliches than to try to be
original and never more so than when
there was something to sell although to
Tocqueville says a lot of really quite
grim things about democracy and America
the top fill wasn't anti-democratic or
anti-american he was just trying to show
why living in a democracy could in some
key ways be really quite annoying and
frustrating he is teaching us the stoic
lesson that certain pains just need to
be expected don't be too surprised or
shocked don't come along with the wrong
expectations politics in a democracy
it's going to be pretty awful in some
major ways it's not that we're doing
anything specifically wrong it's just
the price you pay and should be willing
to pay when you give ultimate authority
to
everyone
you